Earth is 4.5 billion years old
impossible for your brain to truly grasp
so here's an experiment every second
around 1.5 million years will pass
you're on a musical train ride looking
out the window passing all of Earth's
history in an hour watch the eons pass
and experience how long a billion years
really is you can have this in the
background study with it or just enjoy
the ride from time to time I'll say a
few words 4.5 billion years ago right
after it was born Earth was a hell of
lava pretty early in its history Earth
collides with a mars-sized object called
Thea which forms the Moon that you now
see in the
sky right now it looks huge in the N sky
and will slowly shrink over hundreds of
millions of years as it orbits further
away 4.5 billion years ago we are in the
first eon of our planet the hadan named
after the Greek god of the
underworld
at this point the atmosphere is mostly
CO2 and the floor is lava this area of
Earth's history is mostly invisible to
us because almost none of it is
[Music]
left
90 million years have passed we are
still in the lava hell phase settle in
this will take a
[Music]
while
although you wouldn't think it we found
minerals called zircons that indicate
there may have been some water around at
this
time
[Music]
St
he
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
during this period of the young soda
system earth and the inner sodar system
are smashed by a constant heavy asteroid
bombardment for several hundred million
years
[Music]
at this point in time our sun is 30%
less bright than it is today but there
are so many greenhouse gases that it's
still much hot and
comfy
[Music]
around this time we think life begins to
enter the
stage only a few hundred million years
after the beginning of everything the
first cells begin spreading over our
still very deadly
planet Earth continues to cool and it
probably rains for millions of years as
our oceans begin to form covering the
still young planet with
[Music]
water
e
[Music]
oh
these hydrothermal vents we're looking
at and where hot minerals emerge may
have been the place where life first
developed but we don't
[Music]
know
so much time has passed and we're
entering the
pakan most of Earth is still underwater
while the first supercontinents are in
the making in the depths
below its days are shorter since the
young Earth spins
[Music]
faster good job if you're still watching
you've witnessed a billion years so
[Music]
far
[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
from this time in history we still have
stratales sedimentary rocks built by
microorganisms among our first real
evidence of life on Earth also Life is
starting to eat the sun photosynthesis
might have started as early as around
here
3.2 billion years ago in the mesoarchean
the era of continents
begins tectonic plates begin to crush
into each other pulling and pushing some
deep into the Earth where they
dissolve the basis for our continents
today the oceans are as hot as a hot tub
over 40 ° C and microbes are expanding
everywhere we don't have plants yet to
consume greenhouse gases so it is really
really hot you would basically die
immediately in this atmosphere also
there's no oxygen in the atmosphere
yet
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
2.8 billion years ago the neoarchean
begins Earth is still a terribly host H
style place but because we finally have
proper plate tectonics more chemicals
are mixed in from inside the earth and
life can use them to make new
[Music]
[Applause]
things
sometime around here procaryotes like
bacteria begin colonizing the planet
life diversifies more and more but still
after so much time we only have single
[Music]
cells
[Applause]
[Music]
d
oh
[Music]
2.5 billion years ago in the cidarian a
massive event is about to begin that
will change the planet forever the great
oxidation event
oxygen burped out by cyanobacteria
reaches the atmosphere in large
quantities Paving the way for more
complex
[Music]
life
[Applause]
all the new oxygen in the air reacts
with methane and forms CO2 and water
which rapidly cools the planet
down
[Music]
probably for the first time ever the
planet freezes over and a period of
multiple ice ages begins lasting
millions of
years 2.3 billion years ago the ration
[Music]
begins
lots of volcanoes heat up Earth and
Earth unfreezes slowly again melting ice
flushes toxic elements into the oceans
but life quietly puts up resistance and
keeps
[Music]
evolving
[Applause]
[Music]
a
sometime 2.05 billion years ago in the
oryan a large asteroid hits Earth and
creates the largest verified impact
structure on
[Music]
Earth
all over Earth great mountain ranges are
crushed into existence by early
continents with wild names Like Ur NAA
or Atlantica
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
n
1.8 billion years ago in the Stan the
supercontinent Colombia has
formed and a natural self- sustaining
nuclear reactor awakes just from
scattered uranium deposits in the
[Music]
ground
is
[Music]
t
1.6 billion years ago around the edge of
Caliman plus or minus a few hundred
million years or so the first eukaryotic
cells cells with a nucleus merge from
two other cells one of the most
important moments in the history of life
but yes kind of looks not that
impressive still life is only
[Music]
cells
Earth's crust thickens and heavy
continents form the oceans become
shallower also the first fungi like
organisms extend their tubular arms and
do fungi
things
sometime in the ECT asan 1.4 billion
years ago Earth's inner core is
forming weird right Phils like it should
be older but around here it begins to
solidify into an iron Crystal surrounded
by hot liquid metal it will only grow
from now
[Music]
on
[Applause]
[Music]
1.2 billion years ago in the Stan not
that much is going
on except the algae banio morph
pubescence might have Invented Sex a big
reproductive Improvement for many
different
[Music]
reasons
1 billion years ago the tonian begins
another age where Earth is rocks and
puddles and
oceans life is still invisible to the
naked eye it does feel different to
witness it like that
[Music]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
not everybody is having a great time
here we have evidence of the first
unicellular Predators emerging around
that time the dominance of bacteria ends
and big boy ukar plant their Flags in
the oceans an arms race between microbes
begins that again creates huge
diversity some even invent tiny
[Music]
armor
720 million years ago in the cryogenian
earth Freezes Over Again sure why not
how did life survive
we're not
[Music]
[Applause]
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
635 million years ago the supercontinent
gondwana forms a lot of it is still left
[Music]
today
wow what's happening suddenly life gets
big in a hot second multicellular
organisms become widespread it's all
strange alien still but can you imagine
that it took that long for this to
happen 539 million years ago the
Cambrian explosion begins we see life
bursting with variety ancestors of
almost all of today's Major animal
groups appear here while the plants
start to discover the land life is
finally
exciting but of course course a big mass
extinction happens right after killing
most species in the
[Music]
ocean
plants spread over the planet and create
the soil on the ground and change the
Atmosphere by eating
[Music]
CO2
[Applause]
[Music]
things escalate flora and FAA adapt
better and better to life on land we get
trees and forests fish and the first
vertebrate decide this land thing is
something they need to try
out
359 million years ago in the carbonis
forests and Lush marshlands are at their
Peak they will turn into the Cal
Humanity Burns today to keep ourselves
warm it's all so fast now life changes
so quickly in geological time
frames
[Music]
some 299 million years ago in the peran
Pangia the last supercontinent has
formed and after a few tens of million
years the largest mass extinction in
history happens killing the majority of
all species thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
volcanoes 252 million years ago the
triacid
[Music]
begins oh hey a
dinosaur
[Music]
we are now truly in the age of reptiles
dinosaurs are
everywhere the ancestors of the birds do
bird
things life uh finds a
[Music]
way
a
[Music]
Earth gets more and more
familiar
[Music]
[Applause]
such a paradise life is
thriving nothing can go wrong wait
what's
that and an asteroid killed the
dinosaurs and most species on Earth such
a
bummer 66 million years ago in the Paleo
Gene the continents look roughly the
same as today and mammals take over it
is our time now we are almost
[Music]
home
[Applause]
don't blink or you might miss all of
human
history and that was it Earth is ancient
we are new so new this was a project
born of passion we've worked on this
video on and off since 2019 and as you
can imagine it took forever to make but
we did finish it in time for our 10th
anniversary if you want to support
experimental videos like this one please
like share and subscribe and press the
Bell you can also continue your Journey
Through Time with our new timeline of
evolution poster discover how long it
took for the first cellular blobs to
evolve into fish then into dinosaurs and
finally into mammals and encounter
amazing creatures you've never heard of
along the way this poster is part of our
education Edition a poster series that
brings complex topics to life through
extensive research and elaborate
illustrations it's perfect for teachers
students and science lovers get them
from our shop and support what we do on
this channel in any case if you got this
far thank you so much hope you felt
something watching
[Music]
this
n
[Music]